che schifo lo legava vero che si addio
sarà la bella a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenute quest'anno video sono pari j
oggi siamo ad una nuova leccata di
webcam oppure ad un altro episodio di
limbo non lo so come volete voi
buona visione per me puoi tenerti anche
la carcassa non solo la guardo
raggiungere la scala mi fai volare su di
te in qualche modo salta l'ho presa a
sorpresa ma guarda veramente schifo mi
servi solo per perfetto bastava stava
bene ma basta basta molla bene mi
dispiace non volevo non trono non
chiamare la famiglia non volevo giuro ti
saluto in un video sono miopi il cazzo
no veramente giuro non volevo zia porca
merda ma arriva con lo sciame lo sciame
che in confronto le le piaghe d'egitto
erano solo l'antipasto comunque ragazzi
questo gioco si chiama limbo ma è anche
soprannominato stacco le gambe agli
insetti ragni non sono insetti va il
cobra il cover non è un serpente un
altro cammino pieno di case qua
deve trasportare qualcosa che mi serve
ma non ho capito cosa è qualcosa che
deve uscire da qua sicuro è infatti
veloce veloce giro veloce
però come faccio a ok vai vai vai 00
insieme zio por creo è difficilissimo è
più difficile di quanto sembri
è un casino h è ma si blocca ho capito
cosa devo fare comunque anche figo che
torna indietro e ci mette un po a capire
le cose nel caso non si fosse capito
bene perfetto frate minchia questa è una
catena di montaggio porca eva così mila
e soddisfazione dorado sotto se devo
ripartire da dapprima di di quella roba
da a vira grazie a dio
gli sviluppatori avevano intuito che
poteva esserci gente mentecatta giocare
a questo gioco grazie avete la mia piu
totale stima quindi e mentecatti a prove
di questo gioco tanto ragazzino no per
niente capito che cosa ho fatto con
quella roba lì però ok cosa mi serve
[Musica]
lo portava su
no cazzo per fare
devo fare questa roba che ho preso borse
non lo so potrei aver capito se torna
indietro quanto basta per ritornare là
per rotolare fino al liceo perfetto
grandissimo effetto ok
meno male una volta che una cosa che
volevo fare ha funzionato al primo colpo
una da quando ho iniziato a fare gli
episodi su limbo la prima no no no no no
di come la madonna andare io dopo giusto
per forza no non ho mai capito cosa
serva da cassano ok ma ci arrivavo anche
senza ci arrivavo anche senza o sbaglio
o questo dubbio esistenziale
secondo me la scala non serve e devo
semplicemente buttare giù questa per cui
scendere scommettete
provo è uno dei miei tanti tentativi che
di solito sbaglio però ci provo visto
non serviva una sega a me mi fotte vabbè
mai [ __ ] in molti altri modi però va
beh no no no no cazzo cazzo cazzo che
sono convinto che tanto non riesce a
salire vida un torto madonna che genio
che genio out superare gli enigmi before
se sbagli correct english all è uno dei
momenti in cui non dovrei parlare però
lo dico lo stesso e da un po che non
vedo né insetti nei esseri umani e che
credo che non ce ne sia neanche bisogno
e non ci arrivo zio e cosa vuoi che
faccia bilico si ok four forse giusto
no
non è
se non fatta sul fenomeno ma so cosa ho
fatto
cosa va beh lasciamo perdere series è
arrivato troppo tardi bene ragazzi
perfetto abbiamo avanti di qua lo spi ok
per la madonna il caro dio è stato lui è
stato è stata la vespa alla proposta
oddio la madonna ma veramente ma sii
serio cazzo voi che fa scusami se allora
no secondo me ha una certa sia presto
cosa nel pavimento perché vedo che
leggermente staccato un di sicuro sia
per quello apriti zio c'erano il culo a
perché io sono nel culo apice cielo nel
culo abiti sono l'ecologia pro tua madre
abiti o di ok a capitolo importante
minacciare poi capiscono quanti problemi
di qua eh vabbè è quanto casino cosa
devo saltare prima qua ok ma non charlie
non ci arrivò mai lo stesso non ci
arrivo frate ci arrivò invece io non
capisco la lunghezza di sto bambino
regala alle volte fa delle cose che
sbaglia idc come capcom come mi chiamo
io facevo io quando era in fasce come ha
fatto non farlo lui
alle volte fa dei salti nella madonna
non lo capisco
ok che faccio tiro è ok ok ok ok deve
girare tutto ho capito fa parte del
gioco ragazzi si chiama mal di testa su
angolo sulle catene che tanto il mio
passatempo preferito da quando ero
bambino sono ancora un bambino quanto
nei volumi dondolo e sulle catene perché
sono un bambino abbandonato sulle catene
non a un'infanzia però sicuramente a
tutte e due le braccia non far pagare
che ti ammazzo non far pagare giu ok ora
mi raccomando tempi il museo tempismo
tempismo bravo questo e tempismo frate
porca vacca che problemi che gioco non
significa che questo prendiamo dello
xanax tutti quanti prima di giocare sta
roba
fatemi indovinare adesso gira tutto wow
che non avrei mai detto giuro come sono
guarda che faccia sorpresa che ciò vada
giù così che mi va tanto gira tutto
non credevo che la scatola reggesse a
quanto pare no capita altro se stessi
scatole sono piene di divi sono
fragilissimi sono pieni di polistirolo e
piselli e quando vi cadono se mi cadono
addosso muoio mi schiacciano come spiega
temi non so se funziona cipro non ha
funzionato
[ __ ] che fare qua non è che devo
saltare basta c'è da aidan al bar a
[ __ ] un anno e mezzo per trovare le
peggio soluzioni perdono saltare basta
meraviglia una farfalla sii serio o un
animale al quale non dovrò spezzare le
gambe perché non ce la fa chi altro
spesso le gambine [ __ ] nei paraggi poeta
fega vedeva fare l'aperitivo in centro
non è vero minchia quando tenti di
marchiare e le larve si mettono di mezzo
che fastidio io ragazzi tra l'altro
forse rimorchio meglio con una larva in
testa che io normalmente però vabbè con
un dettaglio già è difficile rimorchiare
in questo mondo voi metteteci pure le
larve porca vacca una [ __ ] sola cioè nel
limbo almeno quella no grazie non è che
la luce che mi fa cambiare direzione io
non l'avevo mai capito
un piano scopro cose in questo gioco a
caso c'era una tipa prima c'era una tipa
dove la [ __ ] come lo fermi cosa è
successo c'è una tipa non avevano capito
quanta fa era solo la mia immaginazione
ma quando mi immagino di essere insieme
a a selena gomez e finisce sempre così
il sogno
e vai vai vai vai vai io e zio tenta la
cassa lo sapevo ok perfetto mai mangia
mangia mangia non ci arriva
termina attimo
ok perfetto
per indietro non torna indietro scattato
per una figlia raga perché non c'era una
volta ormai una gioia mai una gioia ma
che cazzo ma è una gioia voglia non di
qua devo ritirare secondo me la leva per
forza quando l'altra prodotto è già
abbastanza sul giusto se si ha o che mi
piace ci mancava solo che sbagliavo la
parte finale
vai zio vai frate all e bene allora
ragazzi ce la possiamo fare
posso sapere perché tutti quelli del
coni del gioco ce l'hanno con lui con le
cose elettriche è il problema che
problema hanno però non ho ben capito il
perché ce l'hanno con le cose elettriche
madonna ce l'ho fatta chi la tira tirati
la verace perfetto ok dai tratte dai
frati wow
ho avuto un orgasmo perfetto a questo
serve quel carrello lo scopriamo subito
quando tiro alla neve perfetto era non
avevo intuito tra c'era anche il simbolo
però io ci arrivo dopo alle cose quindi
ok importante che non sia morto poi va
bene che per lutto storico e madonna che
è che faccio un salto a devo date tutto
buio vedo solo perché già qui
cosa ho fatto ragazzi è tutto buio vedo
solo perché c'è la lanterna st carrucola
somma non vedrai una mazza di niente
vabbè tutto buona la prima raga tutto al
primo tentativo forza
se avete riso siete delle persone
pessime
vabbè niente ancora leccata è stata però
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi con prodotti
ed episodi di imboccare un momento mi
piace anche vari social che il comitato
descrizione presidente ci mettiamo
prossimo video bella ragazza